welcome back everyone this is part five
in our series on methods and metrics
this will be a short focused technical
screencast about data organization
within the field of NLP and indeed all
of AI we're all accustomed to having
data sets that have train Dev and test
portions
this is common in our largest publicly
available data sets
it does presuppose a fairly large data
set and that's in virtue of the fact
that we hardly ever get to use the test
set as I've said repeatedly in the field
where all on the honor System to do
tests that runs only when all of system
development is complete so that test set
is under lock and key most of the time
and that does mean that it goes hardly
ever used during the course of
scientific inquiry
having these fixed test sets is good
because it ensures consistent
evaluations it's much easier to compare
two models if they were evaluated
according to exactly the same protocol
but it does have a downside that because
we always use the same test set we get a
kind of community-wide hill climbing on
that test set as later papers learn
indirect lessons about the test set from
earlier papers in the literature and
that ends up inflating performance but
on balance I think train Dev test has
been good for the field of NLP
however if you're doing work outside of
NLP you might encounter data sets that
don't have predefined splits that could
be because they're small or because
they're from a different field for
example in Psychology you hardly ever
get this trained Dev test methodology
and so data sets from that field which
you might want to make use of are
unlikely to have the predefined splits
this poses a challenge for assessment
right because as I said for robust
comparisons we really want to have all
our models run using the same assessment
regime and that means using the same
splits for all of your experimental runs
now for large data sets you could just
impose the splits yourself and then use
them for the entire project right and
that will simplify your experimental
design and it will also reduce the
amount of hyper parameter optimization
that you need to do so if you can get
away with it just impose the splits and
maybe bake that into how people think
about the data set in NLP now
but for small data sets imposing these
splits might simply leave you with too
little data and that could lead to very
highly variable system assessments right
either you're training on too few
examples to have a lot of examples for
assessment and that causes some noise or
you're leaving too few examples to
assess on and then the resulting
assessments are very noisy and highly
variable so it's hard to get that right
in these situations I think what you
should do is think about
cross-validation
in Cross validation we take a set of
examples and partition them into two or
more train test splits we run a bunch of
system evaluations and then we aggregate
over those scores in some way usually by
taking an average and we report that as
a measure of system performance
there are two broad methods that you can
use for this kind of cross-validation
the first is very simple I've called it
random splits here and the idea is for K
splits that is K times you shuffle your
data set
and then you split it into T percent
train and usually one minus t percent
test to use all the data and then you
conduct an evaluation so you repeat that
K times and you get a vector of scores
and then you aggregate those scores in
some way usually you would take an
average but you could also think about
an average plus a confidence interval or
some kind of stats test that would tell
you about how-to systems differ
according to this regime
usually but not always you want these
splits to be stratified in the sense
that the train and test splits have
approximately the same distribution over
the classes or output values to give you
consistent evaluations
trade-offs well the good part of this is
that you can create as many experiments
as you want without having this impact
the ratio of training to testing
examples the value of K here is separate
from the value of T and 1 minus t
and what that means is that you can run
lots of experiments and independently
set the number of train examples or the
number of assessment examples so that's
certainly to the good
the bad here is that you don't get a
guarantee that every example will be
used the same number of times for
training and testing because of the
shuffle step that you do here
introducing a lot of randomness
frankly for reasonably sized data sets
this bad here is very minimal indeed and
so I really like random splits and I
would worry about the bad only in
situations in which you have a very
small data set
finally scikit-learn has lots of
utilities for doing this kind of random
split stuff I would encourage you to use
them they've worked them out nice
reliable code that will help you with
these protocols
now in some situations you might instead
want to do what's called k-fold
cross-validation and this is somewhat
different let's imagine we have a data
set and we have divided it ahead of time
into three folds that is three disjoint
parts
then we have experiment one where we
have our test fold is fold one and we
train on folds two and three together
experiment two we train on fold two and
test on sorry we test on fold two and
train on one and three and for
Experiment three we test on fold three
and train on one and two so we've
covered all of the combinations our
three folds give us three separate
experiments and then we kind of
aggregate results across all three of
the experiments
let's think about our trade-offs again
the good part is that every example
appears in a train set exactly K minus
one times and in a test set exactly one
so we get a nice pristine experimental
setting in that regard
the bad though is really bad to my mind
the size of K determines the size of the
train set right if I do three folds
cross validation I get to train on 67
percent of the data and test on 33. but
if I want to do 10 folds cross
validation now I have to train on 90 and
test on 10. so it feels like the number
of experiments has gotten
problematically entwined with the
percentage of train and tests that I
want to have and that's really
problematic you might want to have a lot
of folds that is a lot of experiments
but nonetheless train on only 80 percent
of the data in each case
that leads me to prefer the random
splits approach in almost all settings
because the bad there was relatively
small relative to the confound that this
kind of introduces for k-fold's cross
validation
finally I'll just note that scikit again
has you covered they have lots of great
utilities for doing this kind of k-folds
cross validation in various ways so do
make use of them to make sure that your
Protocols are the ones that you wanted